Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday! It's
Question Tuesday, the day that I answer real
questions from real Nerdfighters. Let's
get right to it! "Do rich people have
better Wi-Fi, or does Beyonce have to
unplug the router sometimes?" Interesting
fact: money can buy you almost anything,
but it cannot buy you freedom from
Comcast. I'm pretty sure Beyonce has to
reset her router just like the rest of
us. "How do I cope with the fact that
there's no real meaning in life?"
Oh man, I wish we could just go back to
Beyonce questions. So, listen, maybe meaning
in life is constructed by us rather than
derived from some objective truth, but
that doesn't make meaning not real.
Okay, so, you should always be suspicious of
people who use metaphor to approach
questions of meaning, however, imagine
you're walking through a forest one
night, and you come to a clearing and you
find an eternal fire. It's the perfectly
sized fire and it doesn't need anything
from you. You don't have to put wood in
it, it just burns and burns. And you can
spend your whole life seeing by its
light, and being warmed by it, and so on. I
think that's an awesome fire and if you find
one you should be grateful, but imagine
that you don't. Imagine on your travels
you never come across an eternal fire. In
that case, you have to build a fire and
then find fuel to keep it going and
sometimes it'll go out and you've got to
start a new fire. Now, in some ways that's
worse, but in some ways it's better
because unlike the eternal fire, you
understand how and why it works. Point
being, I would argue the light and heat
from both fires are equally real. Alright,
that's all I got, no more questions about
the meaning of life.
"Will you come to my wedding in September?
My partner is obsessed with you
and your wife." So, when Sarah and I got
married we invited a somewhat famous
person, who shall remain nameless, to our
wedding. He wasn't like a close friend,
but he was someone who'd had an important
role in getting us together. And we
thought it would be nice to invite him.
So anyway, a couple weeks after the
invitations come out, I get an email
and it begins,
"Of course I cannot come to your wedding"
What do you mean "of course"?! Is there a less
necessary "of course" in the history of
the English language? Would not "I cannot
come to your wedding" have sufficed?
Anyway, he did buy us some wine glasses off
our registry, which we still have, so
thank you.
Right, but to your question, of course we
cannot come to your wedding. I'm kidding!
If it's in indianapolis and there's an open
bar, we'll be there. "Favorite fictional
depiction of time travel?" I like your
implication that there are non fictional
depictions of time-travel. Probably, for
me, Back to the Future, which has had kind of
an outsized influence on my life. "Is there
going to be another season of Crash
Course: Literature?" Yeah, probably. What
should we read? "I want to know everything
about your new book." But sadly, I don't
know everything about it, because it's
not finished, yet.
"Are you tired of people asking about your new
book?" No, it's nice that people care, I
just wish I had something more to tell
them. "What's your favorite river?"
Definitely the White River, here in
Indianapolis. Even though Indianapolis
is a city of a million people, the river
is really beautiful and mostly deserted.
Like, you can kayak for hours without
seeing anyone.
And the reason it's so beautiful is that
it's basically a heavily polluted open
sewer, and by basically I mean it is
those things. So it seems natural and
pristine precisely because it is so
unnatural and polluted. It's just a very
metaphorically resonant river. "Favorite
online server to store and organize
information?"
Nice try, hackers, but not this time. "Do
you like the number 53?" Mm..It's probably in my
top half of 2-digit numbers. 43 is the
best, though. "Do you ever go by any nicknames?"
Well, some of my friends from high school
still call me Kuffs, because I once said that
Christian Slater never made a bad movie.
"Do thoughts mean consciousness?" So, like,
I spend probably the majority of my free
time thinking about whether I am
actually comprised of my thoughts, and to
what extent the thoughts that are called
mine actually belong to me, but I haven't
come to any meaningful conclusions.
"Why've people become so obsessed with being
right, rather than developing richer ways
of thinking?" I don't know. I'm trying to
practice saying "I don't know" more,
because, it seems to me, a really
underutilized phrase. "Hey, what's in the boxes
behind you?"
I don't know. "When's your new book going to
come out?" I don't know. "If your greatest
hope and your greatest fear challenged each
other to a duel, who would win?"
So, who would win a duel between absolute
oblivion and a cure for malaria?
I don't know! Hank, this "I don't know" stuff
is amazing. The life-changing magic of "I
don't know"! Hank, I will see you on
Friday. Actually, I don't know for sure
that I'm going to see you on Friday, but
I hope I do.